first the circus of brexit which marked
the start of five years in which we
haven't seen politics as normal
then kovid brought the country to a halt
and much of the government along with it
now boris johnson wants a reset moment
and a plan for public sector reform
which he's put together with the man
he's keeping as chief whip has it gone
well mr spencer
the architects staying in post to help
make change are you going to stay in
place
and that change all in those bits of
government which were seen to have
stalled
a shake-up for education with the man
who led the vaccine rollout will he
deliver catch up for kids and reform of
universities
house building changes stalled can the
most high-profile reformer in this
government restart a troubled scheme
opposed by many tories
then taking on the judges and sorting
prisons reform of judicial review was
promised but ran into the ground can the
new deputy prime minister sort it out
these were all areas that have become
stuck and need careful unpicking
even before the pandemic a lot of public
services were in trouble
if you look at particular issues
planning reform is quite controversial
with the conservative party
there's issues around education reform
not just from covid but it's an issue
the public cares about a lot and then
you've got things like judicial reform
where the party talked a lot about this
in the manifesto
major changes in whitehall with boris
johnson wanting reformers in the biggest
jobs but there's a reason we haven't
been seeing improvement whether it's
lack of money in education tory
opposition to planning change or the
sheer complexity of the judicial system
maybe new faces won't end up delivering
what boris johnson wants
one figure who knows all three said that
they shouldn't be underestimated i've
worked with these people nadine was my
first boss i've obviously worked on
dominic's leadership campaign michael a
special advisor you know i've seen
firsthand that they're doers they like
to grab hold of things and make things
happen and i think if you look at the
reshuffle today it's quite clear that
that's what boris the prime minister
wants to see
from this government going forward
a whitehall reshuffle for more normal
times finding an agenda for the next
phase of his premiership but will events
allow
samcote sky news